chickpea cumin and spinach koftas with
tahini dressing in a blender put tin
chickpeas cumin seeds
paprika
and turmeric
and Blitz to a paste
next we'll spinach in olive oil and chop
finely then add to the chickpea mixture
sprinkling gram flour made from finely
ground chickpeas then shade golf ball
side chunks of the mixture using a spoon
and rest in the fridge when ready to
cook heat oil in a frying pan
shallow fry the koftas until golden
brown on all sides
then rest them on kitchen paper to
absorb any excess oil
for an easy dipping sauce mix yogurt
with a dollar but tahini
and a squeeze of lemon
then stir in freshly chopped coriander
our forcing dish that's perfect for
sharing
chickpea cumin and spinach koftas with
tahini dressing